The Incredibles came out 14 years ago
that is nearly a decade and a half of
Elastigirl been the hottest Pixar mom of
all time doesn't Pixar would it be dizzy
animated moms of all time period
probably quani has been a decade and a
half she's still perfection
[Music]
The Incredibles - so The Incredibles -
was written and directed by Brad Bird
who wrote and directed The Incredibles 1
it picks up literally right where the
first Incredibles left off and now
there's this new guy who's like hey
Elastigirl come with us we got some
missions for you maybe superheroes can
get into a good life maybe this whole
illegal thing could just go away so well
she's off with them mr. incredible stays
home with the kids it needs to be a
stay-at-home dad that's pretty much the
brick and clay of The Incredibles - what
I liked about this movie is they do keep
the family dynamic meet superhero movie
dynamic in fact I watched the first
Incredibles last night or night before
last depending on when I upload this or
when you're watching it but as I wanted
a refresher and it's still perfect but I
realized it's more like a Mission
Impossible movie than a superhero movie
which now it through hindsight I didn't
see it before Brad Bird was perfect to
peg to direct Mission Impossible Ghost
Protocol is incredible it is more like a
Mission Impossible movie than it is a
superhero movie or maybe it's a
superhero movie that's in the Mission
Impossible vein even has a soundtrack
the boy tries to have that old-school
spy trying to the score but it works for
The Incredibles and they kept that score
for The Incredibles - I loved that I was
afraid they were gonna switch out the
score for some other type of score like
all the music's changed we got to change
with it you got to keep it Incredibles
and they kept it incredible also the
family dynamic is very much here I
didn't like all of what they gave us
I'll get to that in a bit but for what I
liked I liked the fact that the
Incredibles - like The Incredibles one
illustrates really what Caesar
illustrates which is Apes together
strong you're stronger together I like
that we got more Frozone in this movie
Frozone other than - is my favorite
character in The Incredibles we get a
bit more of him in this movie you can
see with the ice effects how technology
is it's gotten better when the action is
going down in this movie that's really
where it shines the action sequences in
this movie are better than anything most
movies and or franchises could ever hope
to get really entertaining stuff right
there and really I'm glad Elastigirl
really shined in this movie she shows
everyone yes stretchy powers are not
stupid haters of Fantastic Four it's all
about how you portray it in the film
Elastigirl is great but mr. incredible
for the most part is staying home with
the kids it's the dad who stays at home
to parent the kids who's not used to
being the stay-at-home dad so he feels
out of place in efficient he's
sleep-deprived sound familiar
I know because a lot of movies have done
that it's a cliche what this movie does
it right - you can argue yeah but
they're super kids so violent and - are
pretty well behaved so it's all about
the it's a super baby and that does get
amusing you really
in the end you strip away the mask it's
still the dad who stays at home who's
not used to being a stay-at-home dad
it's the first act of Jersey girl yeah
you didn't miss here that I referenced
Jersey girl the villains pretty cliche
the motivation and you just see it
coming a mile away
I don't mean to make this a review of
Incredibles one but I really felt that
they hit the bullseye was Syndrome in
fact Syndrome would have been perfect to
have an Incredibles 2 rather than
Incredibles 1 thinking Incredibles 1 for
what it was would have been a fine movie
if the villain for this movie was in
that movie they'd have to switch up the
motivation a little bit but it could be
done but still have that scene at the
beginning where it tells that little kid
buddy like right buddy go away didn't
the Incredibles 2 there's this new
Syndrome who's he oh he's buddy from the
first movie that would really tie the
first two second one together the
syndromes perfect for the first
Incredibles but if you're gonna have a
villain who was so closely personally
tied with the hero at least for his
motivation you have to come out swinging
for the villain in the second movie like
Batman Begins personal villain for Bruce
Wayne second movie you come out swinging
with the Joker movie didn't really do
that there's no pre-existing villains in
The Incredibles so you got to make it up
as it goes along but point is I don't
feel Incredibles 2 out did the villain
from Incredibles 1 like a big thing I
can point you right now is the pacing
sometimes I felt the pacing was off
sometimes I felt it dragged on a bit
when it was at home with mr. incredible
and the kids The Incredibles and The
Incredibles 2 are roughly I think
they're the same runtime give or take
two minutes they're each about two hours
long The Incredibles 2 is a two hour
long movie that feels about two hours
long The Incredibles one is a two hour
long movie that feels about an hour and
a half I feel like I'm gonna leave you
with the feeling like I was bagging on
the movie I don't mean for that to be
the case I enjoyed the movie I really
did it was a really fun time it's not as
profound as the first Incredibles movie
like its syndrome for the first
Incredibles movie the entire philosophy
he's going for is a very teachable
moment the idea that if everyone's
special that means no one is that was
the first time I personally had ever
heard that I'm not gonna go so far as to
say it was the first time it was ever
said ever but I remember hearing that be
like oh my god like that's a very real
thing that movie taught me something it
changed my philosophy my perception this
movie doesn't have anything like that
but it's very enjoyable and given what
the villain was and what the villain
could do I feel like there could have
been a moment like that I didn't walk
away with that I don't know if this
movie had something like that for you
that I'm missing comment below let me
know if it a sequel itis in the sense
that sequels are rarely as good as the
first all things considered The
Incredibles 2 was a fun time no alcohol
required rest of the Incredibles 2 have
you seen it why did you
think about it III kind of put me behind
a bit what had this review up much
earlier but hey II three times I imagine
you've seen it what did you think about
it whatever you thought comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]